les concurrents du paris dakar étaient
sur la ligne de départ en cette nuit de
la saint sylvestre le rallye a retrouvé
versailles après dix ans d'absence juste
après versailles direction le trocadéro
mais sur le parcours parisien vous allez
le voir peu de passionnés le paris dakar
a fêté ses 20 ans mais à paris n'a pas
retrouvé sa grandeur passée
béatrice pignède et jean michel maire
ces hommes ne se connaissent pas mais
depuis 5 heures ce matin devant les
derniers fêtards du réveillon ahuri ils
se sont massés sur le bord de la route
pour partager leur passion commune
suffit soit de passer une nuit blanche
soient de se lever tôt j'étais venu voir
le paris dakar était en état triste plus
le revoir
on retrouve en heureux des tarés du
paris dakar ça il le revendique
mais pas en simple spectateur qui
persiste en on essaye de les diriger
dans la bonne direction parce que bon
c'est vrai que ils peuvent pas connaître
tout le parcours parker après trois
années d'absence de la capitale le paris
dakar a voulu pour son vingtième
anniversaire
renouer avec ses origines mais sur la
place du trocadéro ce matin les
parisiens n'étaient pas forcément tous
ravis
bah disons que l'accueil au départ n'a
pas été terrible parce qu'on a été un
peu reçu avec des bouteilles
les jets de bouteilles c'était pas
terrible mais enfin après ça s'est
amélioré tant à versailles que sur le
pavé de la capitale le public n'est pas
venu en masse pourtant les organisateurs
ont tout fait pour ressusciter une
notoriété parisienne mais désormais le
dakar rassemble surtout devant le petit
écran